The simplest way to monetize your
game is with the premium model.
You just submit your game to
the App Store and pick a price.
And most app stores will automatically
convert the price you choose to
the correct currency for all the markets
you want to sell your app in.
For example, if you want to sell to
an American market and choose a price of
99 cents for your game, the App Store
will convert this to the appropriate
currency for other countries,
like 0.75 euros for the European market.
But even though this is the simplest
way to monetize your game,
most games are still free.
People don't want to take the risk of
buying a game that they don't know
much about.
And so freemium games
reach the widest audience.
And it can be hard to choose between
making your game premium or freemium.
In fact,
many developers offer both options.
They offer a free version to
reach as many people as they can.
And also a premium version that has
some benefit for more invested players.
It's really common to have
a freemium option with ads and
a premium version that doesn't.
This way both versions of
the game make money and
the player can choose whether or
not to pay.
Next, let's look at
an example of a real game and
see which monetization
model we think works best.